hello there whether you've just got your
hands on a PS5 or you've had one since
launch here is a list of things you
should know about your PlayStation 5
which Sony didn't tell us about from
Tiny hacks to maximizing battery life
let's do this did you know you can check
the number of hours you've spent on
every game you've played any game from
the PS4 and PS5 era is available and it
may surprise you to know what you've
been playing press the PlayStation
button and go to your profile move over
to games and there you have it
everything you've played from around
2015 I believe what's the game you've
played the most unsurprisingly on the
PS4 I played fortnite quite a bit
another great thing to note is how to
turn off your controllers with one
single button the PlayStation icon when
pressed and held down for 10 seconds
will shut off your controller saving
battery life while not in use great for
watching movies the PlayStation 5 home
screen tracks the last dozen apps you've
opened slowly pushing the other ones out
of right if you want to keep your
favorite game on the home page simply
press the options button and toggle keep
on home it will never leave you again
another great way to group games is in
the game library in your collection we
can create a games list to group things
together like all your Batman games or
psvr games it saves you scrolling
through everything out of Interest how
many games are in your library I almost
have 600. the Dual sense controller is
amazing but for some reason the mic is
always on right away you may be
accidentally broadcasting your singing
to your entire Team without realizing a
setting I recommend is found in Settings
sound and microphone select microphone
status when logged in and switch this to
mute now every time you're on your PS5
by default you're muted and can't be
heard unless you deliberately unmute oh
another cool trick about that mute
button instead of tapping it hold it and
you'll mute everything your microphone
your controller speaker and your TV
audio everything falls silent have you
downloaded the PlayStation app for your
phone you should not only because it's a
great place to check out games see what
your friends are playing and maybe your
trophies too it's also linked to all the
captures you make on your console every
screenshot every video in settings under
captures and broadcasts make sure you
have auto upload on on the app click the
game Library icon and at the top of the
screen is captures as long as your PS5
is connected to the internet it will
send all those clips and screenshots to
your phone allowing you to download them
to edit them or quickly share them on
social media if you like the app has a
ton of hidden extras too you can also
use it to activate games maybe you're
frantically trying to get home and you
want your console ready and set up
simply select the game you want and as
long as your PS5 is in rest mode it will
activate and be ready for you when you
get back another way to save even more
time is to set up device link by going
to system and then HDMI you can enable
One Touch play this means whenever your
S5 is turned on your monitor will
automatically switch on to who needs a
remote and there is a power off version
too when you switch off the monitor the
PS5 will instantly go into rest mode
pretty cool eh for some reason the PS5
doesn't have a dedicated web browsing
app but don't fret people with higher
IQs than I have figured out a way to
bypass that issue by simply using a
direct message to friends you are able
to send links to external sites and by
simply clicking on them you can access
anything on the interwebs from YouTube
to Twitter google.com is a really good
starting place you may be thinking why
would I do this well did you know you
can pin the internet to the side of your
screen while playing by pressing the
option button and selecting pin you can
decide which side too so essentially you
can be doing your dailies in OverWatch
or fortnite and you can take in a
YouTube video at the same time I think
I'll play like this all the time now
double tap the PS button to take your
screen back did you know the Dual sense
controller has gyro functions and you
can use these outside of gaming for
example by pressing L3 and R3 together
you can use motion controls to send a
message weird in it also in these
scenarios the touchpad can be used like
a mouse so the battery life on those
controllers isn't great as they're
packed with so many features so if you
don't want to play with the cable
plugged in or have a second controller I
recommend heading over to settings
accessories controller in here we can
change so much we could reduce the
vibration modify how forceful the haptic
feedback is and even turn down the light
on the controller if you really want to
micromanage your battery life whilst in
here a really important option for
players who use a headset is to turn off
the speaker on the controller if you
can't hear it it's a total waste of
battery life if you want to go on your
PS5 online but don't want to be hassled
by your friends you can log in and stay
offline When selecting your profile
click options simple as that there you
go just pick an option another way
friends can be annoying is when they
accidentally spoil something like the
golf scene in The Last of Us Part 2. to
help prevent this the PS5 has spoiler
warnings built in jump into settings
saved data and game settings and spoiler
warnings May make sure one about game
spoilers is on and now any media sent
via PS5 that could be a game spoiler
will be covered up unless you've already
played past that part of the game pretty
cool back onto the PlayStation app now
did you know it's possible to manage
your console storage from the app by
clicking on the settings icon and then
storage the Blue Line indicates how much
storage you've used yikes in my case and
below it is a breakdown of all the games
currently installed and their sizes I
think it's time Marvel's Avengers got
deleted 113 gig there's also a few
coming soon features you can try right
now such as voice commands in the
settings scroll down to voice commands
and then enable voice commands and now
say hey PlayStation if all goes well
PlayStation will talk to you hey
PlayStation Play Enter the gungeon okay
hey that was pretty cool
hey PlayStation play God of War Ragnarok
okay
it works okay at switching games and
opening apps but it's pretty basic right
now PlayStation are looking for feedback
if you'd like to get involved and if you
do start using this you're opted in
automatically to send feedback when we
tap the PS button and the hybrid menu
pops up press down on the d-pad to
select the icons lots of useful links
and shortcuts should you press the
options button while down here you'll be
given the ability to customize
everything put anything in your own
order or completely disregard it I'm
bringing back the psvr settings icon
ready for psvr 2's release very soon but
if you are not into that just get rid of
it out of sight out of mind to end
here's some of the tiny things you
probably know but I'm going to include
them just in case such as by pressing
the triangle button on the home screen
your cursor will immediately jump to the
search icon in the top right hand corner
it's not impressive but it is useful
double tapping the PlayStation button is
different in almost every app you use
it's actively Dynamic if you're playing
a game something like a trophy card or
activity card will pop up when you're in
chat with friends or listening to music
double tap the PS button and audio
settings will pop up useful I'm sure
you've noticed by now when in game
tapping the PS button doesn't take you
back home like the PS4 days it pops up
this hybrid menu instead just hold the
PS button a fraction longer and there
you are back home and finally something
I only learned this week when playing
local multiplayer games the controller
light indicates players one to four look
one light for one player two lights for
two player etc etc I really need to
clean my controllers let me know if I
should do a part two on this welcome to
the family people who've just got their
ps5s I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see
you next time
foreign